[تصفيق]
الإلهام لـ
مهمة الشرارة كانت
مصدر إلهام للطاقم ونحن نقود السيارة
وشعرنا بالاسم
لنتعامل مع الطاقم في القلعة
[موسيقى]
نحن في دواسة الوقود لأسفل في
دلو دواسة الوقود
لأسفل  استعدادًا
لفترة الحد الأقصى من الضغط الديناميكي
[موسيقى]
وبعد ذلك تكون الرحلة أسرع من الصوت ،
نختنق خلال فترة الحد الأقصى
للضغط الديناميكي ،
وهو أحد التسلسلات المجهضة التي
تعد استدعاءًا رمزيًا ، يستمر كل شيء
في الظهور بشكل
جيد  رحلة سلسة للطاقم
[تصفيق]
لقد بدأنا في تجهيز مضخة السلاحف
في محرك المرحلة الثانية
للإشعال ، ونحن نمر عبر تسارع الجيل الثالث ،
كل شيء يستمر في الظهور
كمركبة رمزية وهي تشق طريقها مرة أخرى إلى
الأرض ، هناك الطاقم على
الجانب الأيمن من شاشتك وأعتقد أنني أرى
بعض الإبهام لأعلى هناك من
الواضح أن الدكتور بروكتور متحمس لأنها
أخيرًا في الفضاء